bankruptcy is expensive AF for many
consumers bankruptcy is out of reach
entirely the idea that they would ever
be able to come up with the money in
order to pay for a lawyer either for
chapter 7 or for chapter 13 is not a
realistic possibility commercials like
this one are aimed at the financially
perilous looking for a way out but with
the evolution of bankruptcy law how much
of a new beginning does bankruptcy
actually give people I had to file
bankruptcy twice I was like I have to
file bankruptcy all my bankruptcy who
does that so if I just I just felt like
a failure hey fam I me mine and this
Sunday we're exploring the complicated
history of personal bankruptcy law and
how it affects how lawyers get paid
[Music]
[Applause]
that's about as painful as a bank job
gift pat sajak is wrong
bankruptcy can and often does get much
worse on Wheel of Fortune bankruptcy is
just a part of the puzzles game of
chance
in reality bankruptcy is a tool for
survival for those who owe debt and are
unable to repay it and the IRL Wheel of
Fortune can cause bankruptcy with
something as mundane as unpaid parking
tickets I felt like I was stuck between
a rock and a hard place whenever you
have to do something that drastic is
with filing bankruptcy I just felt like
why me why am I in the situation it
makes you feel like you're not good
enough
Rachel white was a full-time dental
assistant getting only part-time hours
when she filed for bankruptcy in 2016
the mother of two now teenage boys was
making only $12 an hour
and she'd accumulated about $1,500 in
parking penalties since 2015 penalties
she didn't even know she was getting
they won't have the signs where you can
where you can see them visually you know
throughout the street so I powered park
and I wouldn't see any signs necessarily
and I would end up getting a ticket the
citations were being sent to an address
where her car was registered but where
she no longer lived white bought
bankruptcy was her best option to stay
afloat and keep her car which she used
for freelance gigs like driving for uber
when I initially found bankruptcy the
only I had like tunnel vision the only
thing that I was concerned about is
keeping what I had I didn't really have
the means to just go get another car at
that time and I was just honestly I was
drowning I was just trying to stay
afloat white knew where she'd go to get
help dead stoppers did you know that
song just kept running over and over and
over again in my head she'd heard
commercials for a self-described debt
relief agency based in Chicago called
debt stoppers she'd heard their radio
ads and seen their television pitches
like this one that suffers one of the
nation's leading bankruptcy law firms
we've helped thousands of families stop
foreclosure repossession and wage
garnishment an initial $350 filing fee
got desktop errs to work with white they
found her counsel and she had to pay a
separate fee to that lawyer her
bankruptcy case made her one of the
thousands in the US who've gone through
the process of looking to discharge debt
aka be released of personal liability of
debt to creditors in 2016 more than
three-quarters of a million people filed
for bankruptcy that's the equivalent of
about 20% of Chicago's population that's
that includes all bankruptcy filings
like chapter 7 11 12 and 13 bankruptcy
law expert Megan McDermott says there
are only two options available to
someone overwhelmed by consumer debt you
either file for chapter 7 or chapter 13
so there are a couple of important
differences chapter 7 is a relatively
quick inexpensive and streamlined
proceeding to a discharge usually from
start to finish
a chapter 7 bankruptcy typically takes
at most six months assuming it's a
relatively straightforward case chapter
13 is more a more expensive and more
time-consuming process the debtor is
basically pledging to pay a certain
portion of their future wages over a
three to five year period in order to
pay off their existing creditors the
difference is important because the type
of bankruptcy you choose matters and
Congress has had a big impact on which
is most accessible to you bankruptcy
laws very long history in the u.s. began
when the flag only had 45 stars the
first bankruptcy law became permanent in
1898 that national bankruptcy Act was
the basis of the law for the next 40
years it was amended during the next
several decades including important
changes during the period that gave us
disco dancing like this
[Music]
in 1978 when the code was enacted I
think it did a fabulous job of providing
two very good options for consumers in
different situations but since then
Congress and the courts have really
scaled back the protections that are
available to ordinary consumers and I
think it is fair to say that it does not
provide the same relief that it did 40
years ago let's use student loans as an
example before 1978 you can discharge
all student loans through bankruptcy
after that year you couldn't eliminate
government student loans then in 2005
new regulations meant you also couldn't
get rid of private student debt via
bankruptcy which is why some of you know
Sallie Mae so well Congress tried to
move more people away from chapter 7
where all the eligible debt is
discharged to chapter 13 where you're on
a years-long payment plan the
progression has impacted some of the
most financially vulnerable people those
protections are not available
potentially to the people who need them
the most which is low in very low income
debtors Congress basically made certain
types of debtors ineligible for the
quick and easy relief under Chapter 7
and also took out some protections that
made it easy for low-income individuals
to file for chapter 7 bankruptcy legal
changes haven't only affected debtors
like White who filed for chapter 13
bankruptcy a second time in October 2017
because she couldn't afford to keep up
with the payment plan bankruptcy lawyers
incentives have changed significantly
since 1978 basically when Congress
initially created the code they put a
provision in place that debtors
attorneys would be able to collect but
in 1994 Congress removed that explicit
language sometimes attorneys have added
language to bankruptcy plans that says
they must be paid before any outstanding
debt so basically you could be paying a
bankruptcy plan for years that really
only pays off your attorney your court
costs and yet almost none of the
original debt that forced you into
bankruptcy in the first place like in
this very real-life example
a man owed about $5,000 to the city of
Chicago and parking tickets any file for
bankruptcy and he proposed a plan in
which he would pay four thousand three
hundred dollars over the course of three
years and four thousand of those dollars
were going to pay his lawyer and the
remaining balance went to pay
administrative expenses and so you see
these situations where the client is
going into chapter 13 and the only one
benefiting from this extra time in an
obviously extra judicial effort as well
is the lawyer critics weary lawyers may
steer clients to the much more expensive
and lengthy chapter 13 process even when
chapter 7 is in their best interest
but others say what the lawyers are
really doing when they pay themselves
first is making sure that clients have
representation for the duration of their
bankruptcy plan having a lawyer on
retainer white says she only remembers
being responsible for debt stoppers and
her lawyers upfront fees during her
first bankruptcy and she's unsure of her
payment plan included payouts to her
attorneys we called debt stoppers a few
times to talk about their payment
process but they didn't return our phone
calls when white filed a second time she
got new representation and gave up the
car she tried so desperately to hold on
to during her first bankruptcy to be in
a situation where a parking ticket or a
moving violation did take dictates your
livelihood it's mind blowing I sit back
and think I'm losing everything over
parking tickets these days white lies on
public transportation to get around the
bankruptcy process isn't one white wants
to go through again but the woman
juggling multiple part-time jobs is not
sure she'll be able to avoid it despite
those odds she's still hopeful about her
financial future my life is not gonna be
dictated by debt and bankruptcies and
I'm just ready to move forward
and just keep living work it hey guys
thanks so much for watching don't forget
to like share and subscribe I want to
send a huge thanks to Melissa Sanchez of
ProPublica who helped connect me
with Rachel white and what I want to
know from you guys is whether you've
struggled with any financial
difficulties share your personal stories
in the comments and come back next
Sunday for another awesome video bye